un funcionario de corea del sur habló
con el norte en la línea directa
intercoreana por primera vez desde junio
del año pasado
dado que ahora se han restablecido las
líneas de enlace de comunicación
intercoreanas espero que podamos seguir
dando buenas noticias al resto del mundo
la presidencia de corea del sur dijo que
los dos líderes muniáin y quindio munt
habían decidido normalizar las
comunicaciones fronterizas como primer
paso para mejorar sus lazos dando un
chance a los líderes de las dos coreas
han estado intercambiando cartas en
múltiples ocasiones desde abril para
comunicarse entre sí sobre el tema del
restablecimiento de las relaciones
intercoreanas en el proceso acordaron
restaurar primero las líneas de
comunicación que habían sido cortadas
la agencia estatal de noticias de corea
del norte lo describió como un gran paso
en la recuperación de la confianza mutua
y la promoción de la reconciliación y
que contrasta con la del 16 de junio de
2020 cuando corea del norte hizo
estallar una oficina de enlace conjunta
que estaba vacía en la ciudad fronteriza
de kaesong pyongyang se molestó por el
fracaso de seúl en detener a los
activistas que lanzaron folletos en su
contra a través de la frontera los lazos
bilaterales se estancaron después de una
segunda cumbre fallida en febrero de
2019 entre kim y el ex presidente de
eeuu donald trump una cumbre a la que
nunca se había ofrecido a mediar los
expertos dicen que piensan ahora está
buscando mejorar las relaciones
transfronterizas antes de una posible
reanudación de las conversaciones con el
gobierno de bailén y el deseo de ver una
flexibilización de las sanciones
internacionales en medio de la crisis de
kobe 19